[Music]
Hello friends welcome back to another
episode of top five Skyrim mods of the
week hi Seb you you've never introduced
Hello friends I know I feel we're there
now greetings greetings everybody yes
I'm I'm well I'm in I'm incredibly well
just two of us this week Lucy was here
last week and it was a an incredible
threeway to hack on Skyrim mods I think
um a lot of people actually criticized
us for saying it was only three where
actually it should be four because Kevin
counts he's part of this team he's more
I mean he's more than all three of us
put together Kevin so he's like he's
like the God above the three of us so
how many does he qualify seven we call
that it was atast maybe it was a cool 10
people cool 10 fair enough let's go with
that um but we also got some we got sent
some fantastic feedback from the episode
really guys enjoyed three of us and
actually we got sent some amazing screen
grabs I love the dedicated few among you
who will send us frequently screen grabs
of our own faces pulling like really
weird expression maybe I'm just going to
not pull a single weird expression in
this whole episode good luck yeah try
hard try me you'll never get one you'll
never get one we're both looking dumb
never never anyway um try your best one
of the best we got sent last week was
this one from Carl D on Twitter is sidb
Sid who's been a fan of Gamespot for a
long time a long time you an old friend
of Daniel DWI uh definitely yes uh so
Carl you sent in this picture of uh Lucy
crossfading with the chicken and it's
just like this perfect match the The
Perfect Blend of so much Lucy's face
looks like a chicken and now I I canot
it's all I can see cannot unsee yeah
it's perfect thank you very much for
sending that over but that wasn't the
only one as well uh J Morales sent over
one that said how this week's episode of
top five Sky mods of the week felt um so
SpongeBob that's I believe you are
SpongeBob I of course Mr Krabs and Lucy
is floating Lucy Head floating Lucy Head
yeah my favorite of all the SpongeBob
characters are we reaching for the head
like I don't know we're like lifting her
up or something or just giving her a hug
I don't know who knows it's it's
beautiful all I know is it is beautiful
it's art it's down to interpretation how
these things go yeah it's not what it is
is how it makes you feel and how does it
make you feel it makes me feel like it's
time for mod number one I
[Music]
agree welcome everybody to mod number
one and Kevin is standing Majestic as
ever across the cliffs from Solitude and
actually this week's episode said which
we didn't mention in the in the Preamble
is that it's a special all about Star
Wars I recognize that Moon that's no
moon that's a star well it's it's too
big to be a space a dying star No Death
Star that's that's the one definitely
now I I will confess right from the
beginning of this episode I am no Star
Wars buff in fact before I came to gain
spot I'd never even seen all the
original films I've seen bits of them
fact true fact uh our boss who hired Cam
said that if he' known at the time of
hiring that cam hadn't seen the Star
Wars film any of them any of the films
he wouldn't have gotten the job that's
true although I will say I'd seen like
most of the old ones in bits but just
never all the way through anyway the
important thing have now you have now
and there there's the seventh film is is
not far off star war batt not far off or
everything's looking good so everyone's
talking Star Wars so we figured we
should do a star want to
join we want to jump on that sweet sweet
bandwagon yes absolutely so our first
mod is called Sinister 7 and has nothing
to do with st nothing to do with Star
Wars we're so we're so good at this it's
actually the user requesting mod that
you guys chose last week very long mod
uh you are going to be hun Ed by like
thugs and mobs thieves those kind of
people as well I pity the people who
hunt Kevin Van exactly I mean it happens
all the time you know because there's
there's a trophy out on Kevin little
they know it's impossible but the
Sinister 7even make up seven extremely
difficult bosses are these them I
believe they are them not so Sinister
now and three of them there oh no wait
they weren't they weren't any of them no
that was none of them oh well never mind
so uh the seven bosses will hun to you
over the course of your entire Skyrim
campaign they will always be very
difficult but still winnable and they
will never ever stop chasing you and I
believe this is the first one he a hard
Warrior yeah he's pretty tough I mean
he's no Kevin because chop now I'm not
sure if he was actually one of the seven
or just one of their underlings I think
he was probably an underling uh based on
he just skate down the path head
headless on his knees that's quite way
to go that was exactly how he was
planning on begging for his life admire
that yeah I admire that greatly so what
we're going to do is we're going to just
leave this mod on and we're going to
plow on through the Star Wars mods and
if more mercenaries or more bosses come
after us we'll just kill them as we go
[Music]
perfect okay time for mod number two
which I swear is a Star Wars related mod
it's called Twi race mod Star Wars
that's how I know it's a Star Wars mod
yes it was a clue um so we're going to
turn Kevin into a member of the TWIC
race absolutely I really hope
pronouncing that correctly Twi Twi twil
TW one of them's got to be right we just
cut the right one in every time we say
it ah look Kevin I guess that's that's
Kevin as a twill it doesn't look like
Kevin anymore no it's okay it's okay
that's enough the the T of that race
that have the the long tentacles as you
can see which I found out by the way
helps them like in conversation they
they can do little subtle Twitchy
movements and stff
very very very brilliant that'll help
Kevin with all his oh he's saying no it
won't okay never mind so the thing is as
a male twick it's kind of got this harsh
line between the head and the tentacles
oh yes but I understand that if we were
to be Lady T or twiets if you will I
will um we can get a head uh piece that
will basically mask that horrible line
between the head so you're saying we
should uh change sex there we go we go
piece of cake vanord and we shall be Twi
like vanord for the remainder of the
episode perfect huzzah so tentacles are
clipping just the tiniest little bit but
you mentioned the headpiece we can add
which will make it look less weird so
how do we do that let add let's add the
headpiece aha that is much better it
kind of solves a lot of the clipping
although not quite almost it invents
some brand new clipping has it
hooray so I don't understand why there's
such a gap between her chin and the chin
strap oh yeah but the uh noticed that
but the rest of the the headpiece
obviously aside from where it goes like
into her ears yeah you can kind of see
where it links to the skull a bit is
kind of a hard line there but uh for
some reason there isn't a male version
of this uh so you can only wear this as
as a female twick which is I guess is
fine and it does definitely improve the
mod a lot because they do really stand
out otherwise but yeah um so there were
a couple of different um
Jedi race mods that we could add or just
just general Star Wars law mods but I
kind of like this one because it the
most dramatic in its styling yeah
totally I mean I wouldn't say she fits
in with the world of Skyrim but uh but I
like it I also like it it's
fun hey Sab he's finally stopped dancing
oh he has yeah I I got to be honest I'm
a little disappointed I know he dance oh
oh he but he can jump Le from space to
space Oh What I've Done can is I've I
may or may not or may have left the
fness mod on so that if ever we need him
to just Boogie on that that's the thing
that can be implemented at any time okay
well we'll consider doing that later
let's head in now for mod number four
though right here number three that's
what I said mod number three right into
dragon's reach this week is another Star
Wars related mod in fact it's all to do
with the force what's it called it's the
way of the force the force Star Wars M
and uh so we are due to be sent a note
but the note is taking a while to find
so instead we've come to farengar secret
fire and we're looking for farar farar
where is it where is it oh is that it
the way of the force no that's not it
frequently books are underneath his bed
yes they usually are let's do this uh
started the way of the
force ah the force ah the force been
instructed to find a lot of holocrons oh
and as I understand the holocrons are
going to teach us some new Force Powers
amazing yes so uh choose one choose your
favorite and we shall find it I found it
I've already found it I see it it's a
cubby thing take it Force
telekinesis okay meditation added now I
reckon that's probably a spell I believe
you may be right sir well you can't move
fast while you meditate ah there we go
oh yeah I see it so it it doesn't work
on things as big as bears at padan level
but it does work get off our
Apple
we meditate now yeah come on meditate
harder I'm trying meditate I'm trying
I'm by a beautiful scream whoa Force
repulse Knight added Force grip Knight
added and something else as well let's
have a look oh we got L to them Force
push yeah tot worked oh it's it's pretty
powerful God wo that's more like it okay
yay can I fish the bear of the water yes
moments like this what the the the
moments Frozen in Time where you're he's
sleeping he's just having a we
snooze look at this dirt face D oh and
who's this more hired goons oh looks
like we got another fight on our I think
they're after the bear oh you're here to
kill me are you I think not sir into the
water goodbye friend I'm actually still
holding him so it's like cruel up and
yes well that's good I think that works
oh that's amazing we just leave him
there what I love though about the grip
yeah is that it actually kills them it's
like a Darth Vader choking grip as in
she is now dead oh it's what instakill
not instakill no it drains their their
health over time I must have hurt her
with the repulse as well but and she's
not very high level character but it and
then just just H her away oh that's
amazing this is like such a good mod
it's tiny aha whoops uh-oh I said I said
aha that's cool that's cool it's
different looking so this is Force
lightning let's have it Darth in right
hand and let do electric judgment in the
left okay all right this is electric
judgment that's Force lightning Darth so
Darth all right and that's
Master yeah they're both pretty powerful
they they're kind of just variations on
the Lightning Spell though I was kind of
hoping the Darth one might be a
different color maybe like some red
lightning or something then of course
Count Dooku's uh lightning is also blue
so I of course yeah yeah count duu
D great count
[Music]
San welcome Seb to mod wait wait wait oh
it's The Courier come here oh God he's
dead oh whoops oh God I killed him so
here we are in mod number four we're
here in Riverwood um and we're here
because we need to forge some very Star
Wars weapons let's just uh these bodies
are been annoying me yeah should we get
get rid of
him so here we have loads of different
lightsabers we can install now we've
also as part of this mod installed a
replacer for all the hilts yes now
there's a bunch you can choose from be
have to manually install the file and we
went for the lightsaber based on the one
that Luke has in episode 6 it's
beautiful and if I remember rightly
that's a green saber so we need to make
sure that we get the uh the Green
version all right Seb you ready to wield
like Sabers I'm absolutely ready all
right let's do
this oh that's awesome that's
fantastic predictably it's been made
perfect it's just absolutely spot on we
got the grip in the other hand amazing
okay so can we can we dual wield what do
you want blue pink or Violet uh blue
because we are we are Jedi and you know
oh that's awesome those the the classic
Jedi colors of
course oh moves all right this is when
we really want one of those bad guys to
come try and kill kill us no I don't
think so goat I don't think so
yes no agents of the Sith Lord will get
past me you can poke it ha chicken you
oh God whoopsy daisies I suppose we
should have seen that one coming
definitely agents of the Sith Lord
absolutely oh it's the old or yeah it's
the old or oh I've got you is he dead
yeah he's dead oh wow is that a good
death I think so oh my God a whole bunch
of invisible assassins Jesus ah why did
we consant command these ones in we're
fools we'll be fine we'll be fine all
right just start swinging away swing and
a miss or a
hit oh man these guys are powerful but
they sure do
die oh oh dear an invisible head just
came off y y yep let's hold her until
she appears come on ye give her a jab
show ye there she is yeah that's pretty
great man these swords are really
powerful wa oh dear oh dear oh
dear thanks Bush you really you really
helped us there thanks yeah we were we
didn't want to see that it sounds like
Angry bees lightsabers notic that wa
well that's another head gone are they
all dead I can't even tell I think
they're all dead they were some they
were some trixy assassins well those
lightsabers are pretty good I like them
a
[Music]
lot welcome Seb to mod number five the
final mod of the show not the use the
Roy B cuz we've obviously had that on
all game but this is a very exciting one
for Star Wars it is we've got the
weapons we got the powers now we need
the craft we absolutely do this one is
X-Wing Fighter and it is a fully
pilotable X-Wing CRA and it is just oh
there it is here and it's even got an
R2-D2 waiting for us activate activate
activate hop in and I said hop in in we
get all right so amazing and there we
are so your controls are e to ignite the
engines space bar to exit left alt to
toggle moving and to turning it off W is
go up S is go down a turn left D turn
right and R to just sort of go slightly
sideways
woohoo yeah oh I may have fired too many
weapons what does r do you go sideways
oh
what I think I broke it by firing all
all the weapons think oh s what am I
doing
flying through the skies in my X-Wing
remember ask yourself what would Luke do
you land it with the mammoth use the
mammoth Luke and now just try not to get
oh I got sh up by my own whoops oh I
killed the
mammoth Mammoth hunting is
easy how much shooting did you have it
doing no idea what have you done I don't
know all I know is this is a great photo
op it's
just oh you've bloody broken it and all
I want to see if I can grip the Giant
whoa from Far Far
Away giant surprisingly light yeah super
light go on
Mammoth I Believe In You Mammoth really
heavy just just cunningly lead it into
the path of the oncoming laser
fire Timber down it goes uh so you need
to craft yourself a uh an X-Wing repair
Hammer I think it's R2D2 I I blame him
all right we have the repair hammer hit
it make it
better I think it's cuz you left the
engines on as well you know did I sounds
like a thing I do how have you done that
oh God I don't know what I'm doing
Seb no did you activate it get in I I'm
trying get in I don't know she's now
just running a crap you're a terrible
Jedi you're the worst Jedi ever you're
fired from the Jedi Order that's what
you get where'd he go uh-oh oh no oh I
hope it's all right d we found another
one oh this one looks way better
actually yeah yeah let's add some things
though oh it's a guard up here he's like
he he wants to he wants to go in the
X-Wing I think right should we he like
who it's a pretty good X-Wing right
let's see if we can uh launch activate
the chickens well in the
X-Wing W that was awesome yeah well that
worked yeah didn't get us no I think
we're okay oh wait no chicken bouncing
off the wing all right and she oh we got
it we got it we got it oh it's working
yes we're inited perfect go on and let's
let's zoom out it's better than I hoped
I won't let me do anything no we'll just
have to just going to have to deal with
this disco oh God that's don't look
directly into it oh we're free wa wait
and we're done quick get back in get in
I'm AR in no I'm
not
taada that was amazing with the grace of
a Jedi I'm I'm breaking it I'm breaking
the X-Wing I'm fighting the X-Wing the
epic battle of weird alien versus X-Wing
uh who will win a weird alien yes look
like you won I won you can always get
the X a oh it's made a dmer bits you
turned it into bits who knew a amazing
what up I feel like now I finally
understand Star Wars oh yeah I mean that
was the education you needed in fact
don't even bother with a new film or the
new game just watch that episode over
and over and over
again satisfy your lust for all things
Star Wars It's amazing actually how it
could be both Skyrim law friendly and
Star Wars law friendly at the same time
I think it was spiritual successor hands
off George Lucas this is the next one it
was AIT it's a shame actually that I
don't think we really fought one of the
uh Sinister 7 in the end no that was a
shame so that was obviously the user
requested mod and um well we'll leave
that on for a few weeks and hopefully
we'll be accosted by someone next week
it could be an on-running mod often when
these kind of things happen we can like
cheat cheat our way into forcing it to
happen but there there were no clues of
how to cheat so uh I guess we'll just
have to find out in a later episode
exactly how difficult they are but at
least we know it works it's a cool idea
and you really should check it out yeah
and you should let us know if you can
think of a way for us to trigger it and
speaking of letting us know things we
have questions and comments we do I want
to go with the first one who's from it's
from Simon ruts it says question how do
you make your Skyrim so nice a well we
start with a bit of TLC and then some
love and then we had a whole load of
mods yes and some EMS so I think the
thing that makes it look so nice is that
we did uh so we've done a couple of
graphical overhauls we obviously have a
good MB uh then we've got the uh Skyrim
2K textures we had some um immersive
textures as well I think that of changed
around some of the looks um then we've
got some like Lush trees we've got Lush
grass love the Lush um yeah loads of
stuff like that and I guess the the
thing that makes it look so good is the
fact that we got a machine powerful
enough to run it so yeah this is a
pretty beasty PC right now so uh but
good question Simon ruts um another one
now from anti skill shot who said Kevin
did this Skyrim Shuffle absolutely did
yeah um although was Kevin doing the
Skyrim Shuffle or was the guard doing
the I mean the guard was really
shuffling yeah Kevin was almost doing
more of an MJ thing if I recall either
way it was beautiful it was beautiful
and the next one's from unfailing Eagle
that's a great name superb nobody likes
a fail Eagles never fail no to
kill sorry I like to think that Kevin
murdered the angel of death and stolen
his wings and job I guess I so that's
from one of the ones where Kevin had the
uh the well it was I guess he had the
angelic wings so what was his job to go
around just killing well as an angel of
death it's beautiful yeah he stole the
job of the Angel of Death that's what
he's saying K is just stole the job
murdered the angel of death and sto his
job did he murder him for the job that's
how I got my job here it was murdered a
guy you have to kill your superiors I
had to kill that guy right uh no no no
he gets to live oh oh dear whoops whoops
anyway
um let's move on to a comment from Mr
Mart Gonzo who said DMC got it wrong
Nephilim were The Offspring of the
children of God and the daughters of men
supposedly a race of Giants Well I mean
you would think so because you know go
God was I can imagine big yeah he's over
six foot yeah pretty big now Ultimus 31
had thoughts what were they sir uh am I
really the only one who's freaking out
about how they finally returned bgu's
great sword I mean it's always been
there it's like if the chickens didn't
explode yeah yeah we freaking out too
it's like a weight off our minds and a
literally away up back yeah Kevin feels
a little naked sometimes not having a a
great sword at a moment's notice he's
got another one he's got the the magicky
one that we keep using that I've sudden
the ice blade of the Monarch that's the
one is great uh and finally a question
from
an anilo yes an an Taco an Taco Cam and
Seb should get hearts with Kevin's name
in it as tattoos's big smiley face uh
lovely idea an tattoo tattoo that's not
your name antil Taco that's a great idea
for a tattoo so where where would it be
would it be a would it be a shoulder
come on it's got to be a bicep I was
thinking a full chest oh a full chest
yes full chest that's good big heart
Kevin yeah yeah that's a great idea
that's a great idea done you know for
full commit let's go do that right now
right across the forehead always a good
option always a good option so uh those
are all the comments we had from this
week thank you very much for writing in
don't forget you can always write in you
can leave a comment on YouTube on
Gamespot you can tweet us yep yeah cam
what's your Twitter handle it is camra
Rob and you're Seb oh it's ready sebbio
I realize we often forget to mention our
uh Twitter handles definitely follow us
because we we put lots of silly Skyrim
stuff up there all the time so if you
like the show great yeah my God and so
we good we are high value if you're not
on Twitter you should join Twitter just
for us it's worth it yes um probably
maybe not I don't know should we go to
the let's go to the vote Yes always a
good idea these mods are always worth it
usually and the first mod up for the
vote this week is adamantium second
place mod second place for last week yes
uh I did check by the way does add andom
mantium to the game in X-Men esque
fashion that's what we predicted uh the
next one up is Nea which is a quest mod
and a very big looking Quest mod and
considering how well Sinister 7 went he
hoping this one could go better and uh
and lastly we also have the
Arizer pack that's a great word which
just adds you know back at the beginning
we used to do these like armor packs go
back in the day um we used to do these
armor packs where it would add like 20
new armors yeah like the immersive
armors what exactly like that and then
we haven't done one in ages well this is
one great so awesome a bunch of new
armors always great you know what else
is good I'm really doing great in the
Segways this week new additions to the
Choose Your Own Adventure story perfect
I'm excited about this yes so last week
in the CH Adventure if you remember
balls nasty the York and Kevin vanord
were facing off and blls nasty let out a
cry and you guys had to decide what to
do next and there was loads of crazy
options but the one that you went for
was Sir uh the one that was chosen was
the following with a cry that echoed
through the surrounding mountains balls
nasty embraced the remains of the boat
to soul and wept for you see Ball's
nasty the org and the boat to Soul had
once been lovers no yes they loved each
other to the greatest possible extent
that an orc and a seafaring vessel could
but their romance was not meant to be
after all he was a mortal being and it
was a boat made of dead wood they had
ended amicably at first but Bull's nasty
had returned to the land of solstein in
an attempt to rekindle their
relationship and now all he had was
kindling his sobs transformed into
deranged cackles suddenly balls nasty
threw back his head grabbed a piece of
his former love and rushed at Kevin
swinging wildly Kevin dodged with ease a
person Dodges snails and punched the orc
so hard that it's up to you option A so
hard that time stopped yeah so hard that
the orc's spleen was crushed into a
perfect 18 karat diamond yes so hard
that the boat bits caught fire entirely
possible are so hard that the boat
reassembled and then caught fire and
then caught fire again it's it's up to
you wow I never knew that a man could
love a boat so much I I did I had heard
but i' never truly believed the man the
love between an orc and a boat is a
sacred special kind of love incredibly
anyway find out next week and in fact
more than find out choose by going to
tiny.com camra blog to cast your vote
and once again we have also forgotten to
give the vote link we are just a why do
we work here we're terrible vote for the
Choose Your Own Adventure it is camra's
blog for the vote mod go to tinyurl.com
rybi blog yes of course go to both go to
one then go to the other have your say
yes uh with that said it brings us to
the end of yet another episode of top
five scar of the week I I don't know if
it's good or bad that it's back to us
but it is back to us I think it's good I
mean Lucy's great and we will I I reckon
we'll probably do another one with all
three of us because they're fun I think
I could almost promise we will yes all
right I like that mhm we like promises
well we'll promise to bring Lucy back if
you come back next week absolutely
promise good see you
[Music]
then